hey 42 here one of the greatest myths of
childhood is that when we grow up we'll
finally be in charge but whilst it's
true that reaching adulthood means you
get to choose your own bedtime and eat
pizza for dinner every night the idea
that we suddenly become masters of our
own Destinies is simply an illusion
whether it's paying taxes or staying at
home during lockdown sometimes we all
have to do things we don't want to do
still aside from the rules and
regulations passed down by the
government our employers and our
partners we like to believe that our
Destinies are ours and ours alone to
make but even that's far from a sure
thing
philosophers and thinkers have been
debating whether or not we truly have
free will ever since some guy in a toga
first wondered why on Earth he drank
that third flagon of wine last night
don't worry I'm not going to open that
philosophical can of worms I have
another whole video dedicated to the
topic of free will but suffice to say
humans are quite attached to the notion
of being autonomous beings that get to
choose their own path in life and it's
not hard to see why to believe the
opposite is to accept that our futures
have already been laid out before us and
that we are mere NPCs rather than active
players
you might even say we'd be no better
than zombies which would actually be
quite handy because then I could
casually segue into the topic of today's
video real life zombies
I don't know about you but taking half
an hour out of my morning to cook
breakfast just isn't an option there's
always so much to do but luckily huel is
here to help rescue my hectic mornings
for me huel is a nutritionally complete
breakfast that I can make in literally
30 seconds it fills me up it has all the
essential goodness that humans need to
function and most importantly it doesn't
interrupt my workflow to make a heel
Shake I simply add 500 mL of water to my
heel shaker bottle add two scoops of
fuel powder and give it a good shake my
favorite is this black edition cookies
and cream I can't believe this stuff is
actually good for me because it's so
rich and chocolatey with a hint of
cookies and cream is really good hewell
is an easy way to maintain and keep on
track of nutritional goals it's packed
with 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
gluten free oh and it's really
affordable so click the link in the
description to try huel today if you use
my special link you'll be supporting a
channel and you'll also get a free heel
shaker bottle so don't miss out and
thanks to huel for sponsoring this video
now if you're going to be a scientific
wet blanket and declare that there's no
such thing as zombies I suggest you
visit IKEA on a Saturday afternoon and
see for yourself
pay close attention to the faces of the
men aimlessly pushing trolleys nodding
guns smiling when asked whether they
prefer the skog school and Scatter
cushion or the tour of South notice the
emptiness in their eyes their vacant
expressions and the way they follow the
arrows of flat pack Doom as if slaves to
some unseen Force admittedly that force
is probably the promise of Swedish
meatballs and a slice of dime cake
rather than the chance to Feast on the
brains of the living but still
of course it isn't just really big
Scandinavian furniture shops that have
the power to turn living beings into
mindless zombies that utter sadist
Mother Nature is pretty good at it too
because real-life zombies are
surprisingly common in the natural world
take for example
plesiometer aguiro this poor spider is
routinely chosen to play an unwitting
and unhappy support role raising the
young of a certain parasitic wasp whose
breeding habits read like something out
of a horror film
the WASP starts by paralyzing the spider
with a single sting before laying her
larvae on the surface of its body
along with The Unwanted babysitting gig
the spider receives another Sinister
surprise brand new biological coding
the Wasps larvae begin to grow sucking
on the spider's bodily fluids through
tiny puncture holes they make in its
abdomen
to begin with the spider basically just
goes about its regular spidery business
as if a host of tiny parasites aren't
making milkshakes out of its insides but
after two weeks something changes
through a mechanism we still don't
understand the spider will suddenly stop
tending to its large circular web and
will instead feel compelled to craft a
small sturdy platform unlike any web
it's ever woven the spider will spend
the last night of its life on this
crazed construction project and its
reward for finishing is to be eaten
alive by the hungry larvae hanging out
in its abdomen
with that final nutritious meal in their
bellies the larvae will begin spinning
their cocoons which they neatly hang
from their bespoke spiderweb scaffold
another real-life zombie is the
woodlouse also known as the pill book a
common household Critter with a fatal
fetish for feces
this little poo Nibbler has a particular
healing for bird droppings including
those deposited by Starlings
unfortunately for the pill book stalling
digestive tracts often carry a parasite
that's far more dangerous to the book
than it is to the bird
once safely ensconced inside the pill
book this parasite seizes control
to complete its life cycle the parasite
needs to make its way back inside a
starling and so it compels the wood
lives to seek out the most exposed
location it can find nothing is as
tantalizing to stalling taste buds as a
pill bug out in the open dancing the
Macarena
so the insect is soon gobbled up and the
parasite goes back to colonizing the gut
of its original host
clever disgusting and horrifying but
clever
the green banded brood Sac uses similar
poo based tactics although this time
it's a species of snail that eats the
bird's feces now it's well known that
snails are absolutely terrible at the
Macarena
so The Brood Sac has yet another way of
attracting the interest of the local
bird population it grows directly into
the snail's eye stalks where it begins
to throb and pulsate causing the snail
to do a surprisingly good impression of
a caterpillar
and before you can say Simple Simon in
swoops a bird to gobble up the snail and
The Brood sack along with it
now as horrific as all these examples
are nothing strikes as much Undead fear
as fungi
the natural world is made up of multiple
kingdoms with the most well-known being
plants animals and Narnia fungi which
includes yeasts molds and mushrooms have
a kingdom all to themselves and judging
by the name it's where you want to go to
have a good time
there are of course many different types
of fungi that do many different things
including entomopathogenic fungi that
infect and often kill insects
[Music]
one such fungus is Bavaria bassiana that
can be found growing in soils all over
the world it infects insects and other
anthropods by penetrating their
exoskeletons and growing inside them
killing them within a few days
if that was all this fatal fungus did
I'd consider it to be pretty bloody rude
but no Bavaria bassiana then proceeds to
colonize the poor insects corpse its
spores appearing all over the dead body
before drifting off into the air in
search of more stuff to murder
Bavaria bassiano is so good at wiping
out certain types of insects it's
actually used as a biological
insecticide to control bugs like
termites aphids and beetles
it's safe to say Bavaria bassiana
behaves brutally but as far as
entomopathogenic fungi go it's actually
one of the friendliest unlike a
particular Genesis fungi known as
cordyceps which are found worldwide in
tropical and temperate regions and
cordyceps have a very particular skill
it doesn't just kill its hosts it first
releases chemicals into their brains
taking control of their bodies and
turning them into automatons
no wonder it's known as the zombie
no one knows exactly how many cordyceps
species there are but there are at least
600 and most targets are single species
of insects anything from butterflies to
dragonflies and cockroaches
afio cordyceps curcolianum attacks
weevils in Central and South America
afio cordyceps senesis kills
caterpillars up in the Himalayas and
otheocordyceps humberti infects wasps in
Brazil
causing them to land on a leaf or branch
and bite down into it before passing
away
this peculiar behavior is also seen in
the effects of the otheocodeiceps
unilateralis probably the most famous of
the cordyceps fungi and Scourge of ants
across the globe
like its fellow zombifungi unilateralis
gets inside its victim using special
enzymes that dissolve cheating the
fibrous substance that makes up most
anthropods exoskeletons
once inside the fungus takes control of
the ant's brain forcing it to climb high
into a tree where it bites down on a
leaf and then pops its six tiny clogs
soon the fungus begins to bloom growing
out through the ants exoskeleton into
balls of spores that burst and shower
down on all the ants scurrying across
the forest floor below starting the
process all over again
[Music]
it's a terrifying mode of operation but
it's also highly successful because
cordyceps have been playing this game
for a very very long time fossil records
show zombie ants controlled by cordyceps
like fungus were taking their last bite
into a leaf at least 48 million years
ago other researchers have found a
fungus infected insect stuck in Amber
that goes back more than 100 million
years
part of the reason for this success is
fungi's adaptability
scientists recently discovered that ants
are sometimes colonized by more than one
species of cordyceps originally it
looked like the two different parasites
were living in harmony but further
research suggests that this is probably
an example of hyperparasitism a
situation in which one parasite becomes
infected by another
I said earlier that fungi eat into
insects bodies by dissolving the chitin
in their exoskeletons well guess what
also contains plenty of chitting fungi
so in another weird turn fungi are
practically designed to infect each
other which is why some coreyceps
cannibals specialize in attacking other
cordyceps
so we're talking about a hyper adaptable
organism that can colonize something
thousands of times bigger than itself
taking over its mind and forcing it into
some form of ritualistic suicide
Yeah by now there should only be one
question on your mind
but don't worry there's no reason to
believe humans can be infected by an as
yet undiscovered fungus and turned into
real-life clickers from The Last of Us
in fact it's kind of the opposite
we may be able to use these fatal fungi
to our advantage
cordyceps fungi contain a chemical
called cordycepin that in biological
organism switches on a cellular protein
called ampk and it turns out ampk is
pretty powerful stuff initial tests
suggest drugs that trigger ampk
production in our bodies are able to
reverse some types of diabetes and
cancer limit heart disease and even make
us live longer
and now scientists think they've found a
way to grow cordyceps fungi effectively
in Laboratories potentially opening up
the way for new antiviral and
cancer-fighting wonder drugs based on
cordycepin
of course it might be a hard pill to
swallow when you know the medicine
you're taking is made from a zombie
fungus
then again maybe this will grow on you
thanks for watching